this is the beryllium which that we want
to get out
it's got because it calls well because
it's a toxic chemical toxic and metal
beryllium is an interesting element
because most chemists don't really know
about it very much at all but brilliant
dust actually has been shown to cause
brilliance which is actually a and
industrial lung disease which causes the
formation of swollen sort of nodules in
the lone that's called granulomas which
is a bit gross so I don't really want to
open up the jar but it's actually a
brilliant a sort of silvery sort of
metal and it's actually at the top of
the group T or the alkaline earth metals
so it's pretty lightweight actually does
have uses although giving it's not to
see yes it's actually quite useful
sometimes it's near the beginning of the
periodic table but we rarely come across
it I talk about in my lectures I
explained that beryllium chloride the
molecule that has three atoms two
chlorine atoms and one beryllium atom
has the three atoms arranged in the row
so it's a straight molecule so-called
linear molecule I never seen beryllium
chloride chemists use it in x-ray
diffractometer because actually it's so
lightweight it's actually only got a
point there before it only has four
protons and a number of neutrons so if
x-rays fall on atoms of beryllium
they're not scattered very much so it's
like the difference between shining
light through a glass window and if you
made it out of a heavier material be
like shining through paper it would be
scattered you wouldn't get a good image
I'm hoping to actually do some chemistry
with beryllium which is why I've bought
it yeah it's pretty toxic so I'm we're
gonna have to be very very careful you
can't actually breathe in the dust at
all cuz even actually one exposure is
shown that some people would prefer one
exposure is enough to cause this sort of
sensitive reaction but beryllium is very
poisonous so if you do use the these
beryllium windows you have to be careful
not to lick your fingers well good
chemists shouldn't lick their fingers
anyway